un satélite de masa m orbita la tierra
con un radio r y una rapidez v0 como se
muestra en el diagrama un ingeniero
aerospacial decide lanzar un segundo
satélite que tiene el doble de masa a la
misma órbita aquí en el diagrama vemos
que es la misma órbita con radio r
mayúscula y este segundo satélite tiene
una masa 2 m la masa de la tierra es m
cual es la rapidez v del satélite con
mayor masa en términos de v0 la rapidez
es la magnitud de la velocidad y es por
eso que usamos v mayúscula si en el
símbolo de vector arriba nos piden la
magnitud de la velocidad necesaria para
que el segundo satélite se mantenga en
órbita a que será igual v minúscula
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto por
su cuenta
recordemos que la única razón por la que
algo se mantiene en órbita en lugar de
seguir una trayectoria recta en el
espacio es porque hay una aceleración
centrípeta de magnitud constante cuya
dirección es hacia el centro de la
tierra que es lo que hace dar vuelta por
decirlo de alguna manera la trayectoria
del satélite y lo mantiene en una ruta
circular en
videos hemos visto que la magnitud de
esta aceleración centrípeta es igual a
la magnitud de la velocidad por ahora
vamos a usar la velocidad de este primer
satélite así que es la magnitud de esta
velocidad al cuadrado dividida entre el
radio que en este caso es la r mayúscula
pero qué es lo que determina esta
aceleración centrípeta podemos utilizar
la ley de gravitación de newton para
determinar la fuerza de gravedad sabemos
que es igual a g mayúscula que es la
constante de gravitación universal
multiplicada por el producto de las
masas cuya fuerza nos interesa en este
caso es el producto de la masa de la
tierra que es m mayúscula multiplicada
por la masa del primer satélite que es m
minúscula recordemos que por ahora
estamos analizando el primer satélite
todo esto dividido entre el cuadrado de
la distancia que hay entre los centros
de masa que en este caso es r mayúscula
al cuadrado
si queremos conocer la aceleración
centrípeta solamente tenemos que dividir
la fuerza entre la masa recordemos que
esto viene de la segunda ley de newton
sabemos que f es igual a m por a si nos
interesa la aceleración centrípeta
entonces usar
la fuerza de gravedad que le está
ocasionando si queremos despejar la
aceleración centrípeta tenemos que
dividir ambos lados entre la masa que es
la masa del satélite por lo que la
aceleración centrípeta es igual a g
mayúscula que es la constante de
gravitación universal multiplicada por
la masa de la tierra y dividida entre el
radio al cuadrado ahora podemos tomar
esto y sustituirlo aquí arriba y
despejar la magnitud de la velocidad que
nos piden tenemos la constante de
gravitación universal multiplicada por
la masa de la tierra dividida entre el
radio al cuadrado que es igual a la
magnitud de la velocidad de al cuadrado
dividida entre mayúscula
multiplicamos ambos lados por r
mayúscula e intercambiamos los lados
para que quede más claro v0 al cuadrado
es igual a g mayúscula por m mayúscula
entre r mayúscula aplicamos la raíz
cuadrada en ambos lados de la igualdad y
nos queda que v0 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de la constante de gravitación
universal por la masa de la tierra entre
la distancia de los centros de masa aquí
observamos algo interesante
de la rapidez necesaria para mantener
esta órbita no aparece para nada la masa
del satélite en esta expresión no
aparece la m minúscula para nada y ya
que esto es independiente de la masa que
esté en órbita
no importa si duplicamos la masa del
satélite si pasamos de m minúscula a 2 m
minúscula esto no modifica la rapidez
orbital necesaria así que cuál es la
rapidez v necesaria para el satélite con
mayor masa en términos de v0 pues va a
ser la misma v es igual a v0 no importa
que hagamos con la masa que está aquí
arriba siempre vamos a necesitar la
misma rapidez orbital con eso terminamos
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo